one neighborhood near a high school is
noticing a big buildup of trash yeah
it's happening in a community not too
far from desert oasis high school near
rainbow and cactus 8 news now reporter
sally jaramillo visited that area today
and tells us
a lot of the hazards that you found out
there sally
brian and denise you won't believe it we
found tires mattresses patio furniture
shopping carts and even dressers after
speaking to some who live near desert
oasis high school they say it's time to
do something so no one gets hurt
you know when i was younger there was a
lot more empty spaces so we used to go
out with our bicycles and dirt bikes rob
piston visits the area from time to time
he likes to walk around the empty land
space and says it's heartbreaking to see
bulk trash in our valley you realize the
town is growing it's our
community duty to make sure that we keep
the town looking nice especially these
natural areas monica grester has lived
in las vegas for 21 years she lives a
quarter mile away from desert oasis high
school and says trash keeps increasing
each day gradually over the years every
now and then you'd see
furniture
and then
you'd see
landscaping trees and then i guess more
recently there have been
tires gresser says over time it's
becoming hard for pets children and
people who walk there i mean one it's an
eyesore and two it's it's just not a
dumping ground and wishes people would
reach out to republic services for help
i wish you would put it out for our
public services to pick up on bulk day
because we have that and that's twice a
month and that could that would be much
better for the rest of us and grezer
isn't alone as carl meisner who lives in
mountain's edge says he too is familiar
with the mess besides just making
everything look trashy it's frustrating
we have kids who want to play outside
and can't there's just no excuse for it
i reached out to republic services who
said they pick up bulk trash every two
weeks and encourage people to go to
their website to find the nearest public
dumping location we put that and also
how you can report illegal dumping on
our website eightiesnow.com brian sally